we begin this morning with our top story
yet another Trump administration
shake-up Steve Bannon the president's
chief strategist was ousted Friday while
the president was at Camp David for
national security meetings Bannon was
the architect of an architect of mr.
Trump's election victory but as a
far-right nationalist he was also a
contentious presence in the White House
after his meetings the president
returned to his Golf Course in
Bedminster New Jersey without any
comment about Fannin's departure Errol
Barnett is in New Jersey with the latest
Erol good morning good morning
White House officials claim that Steve
Bannon and Chief of Staff General John
Kelly mutually agreed that it was time
for Bannon to go but sources tell CBS
News that President Trump has been
frustrated by bannon's
rising profile and by media coverage of
Bannon as the real mastermind behind
President Trump's campaign president
Trump arrived in New Jersey Friday amid
unanswered questions about his decision
to fire chief strategist Steve Bannon
we'll see what happens with mr. bannon
at an explosive press conference earlier
in the week the president refused to
express confidence in Bannon and
downplayed his role in the 2016 campaign
mr. banek came on very late you know
that I went through 17 senators
governors and I want all the primaries
mr. Bannon came on very much later than
that as one of mr. Trump's first White
House hires
Bannon arrived with a nationalist agenda
claiming shortly after the inauguration
that he was ready to fight for a new
political order if you think they're
gonna give you your country back without
a fight you're sadly mistaken
every day every day it is going to be a
fight Bannon had been a consistent
lightning rod for criticism partly
because of his work for Breitbart news
but within hours of his firing the
outlet announced he would return as its
executive chairman and in an interview
with the Weekly Standard Bannon said his
departure signals that the trump
presidency his movement fought for is
over but returning to Breitbart meant
he's got his hands back on his weapons
and he vowed to crush the opposition
many explain okay I said he was unafraid
to feud with other White House officials
Bannon had publicly butted heads with
several colleagues including a recent
clash with short-lived communications
director Anthony scaramouche II he had
to be gone in a week that's up to the
president but what do you think what do
you think what does the mooch think well
if it was it was up to me he would be
gone okay but it's not up to me now now
the Weekly Standard interview was just
one in a series of really exit
interviews for Bannon that he gave this
past week in an earlier exchange he
contradicted the President on North
Korea and called for a maniacal focus on
China now back at the helm of Breitbart
Bannon says he is jacked up and will
likely continue the feuds that he began
while he was in the White House and the
White House has just announced that
President Trump will not participate in
the Kennedy Center Honors so as to not
be a political distraction Anthony
Farrell Barnett in New Jersey Thank You
Errol